in the last video we had this situation
where we have to buy a truck every three
years because that's how long they last
and we were at first just expensing the
truck so it's sixty thousand dollars
every three years but it did something
very strange to our operating profit it
made it look like the years that we
bought the truck that our business
didn't do well and then the other years
it did really well even though this was
a really consistent business so what we
hinted at at the last video is maybe we
can do something called capitalizing the
expense we could capitalize the truck so
what we do is instead of just saying
that the truck is an expense we say that
we're buying an asset that has some
useful life beyond the time that we're
just expensing it so what we do is let's
just put a balance sheet right here at
the beginning of year one so the
beginning of year one this is our
balance sheet balance sheet right over
here and we're by capitalizing a truck
we are essentially saying we're going to
spend $60,000 let's say we started with
$60,000 in cash we use that $60,000 in
cash to buy a truck so on our balance
sheet we now have only one asset called
a truck let me do it this way so in the
asset category we have a truck and we
are saying that right when it's brand
new it is worth $60,000 and we have no
liabilities so I'll just put a zero
there and so our equity our shareholders
equity is 60,000 minus 0 which is 60,000
our company is worth $60,000 on our
books and the way that we account for
this truck that lasts three years is we
say well look this has a useful life of
three years essentially let's just
spread that $60,000 out over the three
years or another way to say it let's say
that this truck is costing us $20,000 a
year $20,000 a year or another way we
can say that is that we can depreciate
the value of the truck and that
depreciation is an expense so
depreciation of truck so instead of just
calling a truck I'll call it the truck
depreciation and you could just really
view this as a way of spreading out the
cost of the truck so in the
first year we're going to depreciate our
truck by twenty thousand we're going to
say that it's one third one third of its
value has been served or it's now twenty
thousand dollars worth less at the end
of the year than it was at the beginning
in the second year twenty thousand in
the third year twenty thousand so we
just really spread out the sixty
thousand over the life of the truck and
what that does is is it makes our
operating profit consistent which it
should be because we have a very
consistent business one hundred minus 50
minus twenty we make 30 and year one
thirty and year two thirty and year
three and then we just keep going these
all become 20s and so because we have
such a consistent business we make
thirty thousand dollars the whole way
through now what does depreciation do to
our balance sheet so at the beginning of
year one we had a truck that was worth
sixty thousand dollars if you forward to
the end of year one or the beginning of
year two what's going to happen is
because we're depreciating the value of
the truck on our balance sheet we took a
twenty thousand dollar depreciation
expense on our balance sheet the value
of the truck over the course of the year
will go from sixty thousand to forty
thousand to forty thousand and then at
the end of year two if we go another
year forward the value that we keep the
trucks on the books for will go down to
twenty thousand and then at the end of
year three it's going to go down to zero
and then we go buy another truck so
we'll go back to sixty thousand will
keep going but the cool thing about this
is it makes the expense very consistent
and actually more consistent with what
our business is actually doing